fox news witnessing more than 500
illegal immigrants coming across the
border this morning alone
including this huge single group of 290.
this as dozens of migrants arrived from
new york city from texas this morning as
the surge along the southern border
forces fed up governors to send them
north
and here's another problem developing
from those buses the migrants who were
in the country illegally threatening to
call the cops for help
the new york post reporting quote some
of the passengers on the new york bound
bus became upset when the driver
announced a change in the itinerary
pleading for hours to make the plan stop
many had plans to meet relatives or
travel from chattanooga
the state of texas gave them envelopes
with what bus stop they were supposed to
get off at ultimately they said the bus
did stop in chattanooga
man has just gone off the rails
you know i i was looking
today
getting prepared for this
at how we used to deal with
illegal immigration and when the country
began
the assumption was that the state
governments were going to police their
internal territory and the federal
government had almost no
authority over this whatsoever so that
that's kind of an invention of the
courts in the last century
um
and i just wonder what what happens is
you know you s you take something that's
a federal of state responsibility turn
it into a federal responsibility uh and
then it goes
uh off the rails and they take the
position in washington that the states
can't do anything about it so is this
just tammy let me ask you first is this
just
a federal state problem or is it like
progressivism run amok colliding with
its various aspirations well you know we
see progressivism in a certain way now
like with the squad and there's you know
little actors involved in what that is
but clearly this has been a problem for
the last 50 years i mean we've seen this
moving forward
ranging from with even
governor and then president reagan and
promises to build a wall or to secure
the southern border which never occurred
and so you've seen this game back and
forth with democrat and republican
presidents as many of course when it
comes to president bush the first know
that this has been a problem for a long
time but there is an interest clearly at
the federal level when it comes to
redistricting how you get power yes
voting the nature of the worker
framework the chamber of commerce
issues of wages and also look as america
we are a nation of immigrants so this is
not so far off from who we how we view
ourselves which is welcoming and come
over here and of course we're the great
who wouldn't want to come here the
problem becomes is as you've said it
goes off the rails when you've got a
bureaucracy so big it doesn't know how
to handle this and real people's lives
are at stake right these are
there's some who viewed the migrants as
being uh like children somehow but these
are strong hearted people
ex long time cultures that they have to
flee their own home which is horrible
coming to this nation these are not
babies simply because they're not white
they have they speak a different
language they come here and often thrive
but now the government makes kind of has
a ceiling of keeping even those
individuals down americans are being
kept down so it is it goes off the rail
it becomes it is a federal issue because
of federal interest and uh states of
course then become overwhelmed because
of the other existing economic problems
so everybody loses uh and the migrants
get pushed off to the side and harmed
even more the sex trafficking the drug
trafficking the communities if they end
up homeless
this bus issue
um it becomes a problem i i find it uh
dizzying to try to stay on top of this
because during the obama years what we
heard was the federal government runs
this and the states had nothing to say
and then the states all became
sanctuaries right and we heard that in
fact i think we have some something from
kathy hokel the governor of new york
about
oh okay i just did a farm tour upstate
new york
they're begging for workers i walk the
streets of manhattan i walk the streets
of albany there's help wanted signs
everywhere where they're begging for
workers so now it's all
peachy
well
first of all stop paying people to stay
home and get americans back into the
world to begin with i disagree with you
a little bit tammy i mean you say that
they're strong-hearted people and some
may be but some may not be we're not
vetting people who come into the country
so we don't know who they are uh you
have good people bad people some people
sugared in some people should not but
when you just have streams of people who
come in who aren't vetted that's a
problem for one our workforce and our
national security and my frustration and
maybe this goes to your question andy
you have states that have no control
over the border and who's coming into
their state people are flown in busting
and it's the states that are required to
pay for the schools and the hospitals
and the housing for migrants who the the
federal government is allowing into
their state and i think what you now see
happening is liberals love this policy
but they don't want migrants in their
backyard like we see in new york and in
dc just like they want to defund the
police but not in their neighborhood
they want to
let criminals out of jail but not in
their backyard they don't want people in
their gated communities so they have
policies and philosophies that they
think are great for everybody else but
not for themselves they're they're
hypocrites and again secure the border
and again we are a nation of immigrants
tammy let people in but we should know
who they are are they going to work are
they going to suck off the system can i
just say one thing before we go um kathy
holcol also said in that quote this is
actually good for our economy and it's
so interesting to me that she and mayor
adams are so at odds on this issue
apparently she wants them to come here
mayor adams who called this a sanctuary
state now does not want them to come
here um because he can't provide them
housing he can't provide them the things
he needs at least that's what he's
saying right now and i agree with you
sean part of the problem you see to help
wanted ads and people don't want to be
servicers and restaurants and whatnot is
not necessarily because we've got a
labor problem it's because people are
getting things like in the inflation
reduction act expanded healthcare they
know if they stay home long enough the
government will help them where they
don't have to return to work that is why
this has gone on more than two years
yeah i'm glad we're able to solve that
[Laughter]
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else